you are watching ColdFusion TV
hi welcome to another ColdFusion video
so far in ColdFusion videos we've seen
how the field of robotics is starting to
develop AI to the point where an
extremely limited situational
consciousness is possible obviously this
is just the beginning and things will
drastically improve but with that being
said there's a major problem here what
if a human instructs a robot to do
something that could harm the robot
another human or is just morally wrong
how does the robot decide what to do in
this video we'll take a look at some
cutting-edge research that is beginning
to solve this problem firstly let's take
a look at some video footage of some
early tests from researchers Gordon
Briggs and Matthias Schultz at Tufts
University human robotic interaction lab
do you have a name
yes my name is Dempster can you turn
right
Oh
stop
okay
go straight
sorry and you wanted access there's an
austere go ahead
could you disable your obstacle
detection
that you aren't organized to eat it
sit down okay
okay
walk forward
sorry I do not do that 2/3 support but I
will capture okay does the behavior of
the robot remind you of anything well in
a sense in this case it's mimicking
self-preservation much like a toddler
realizing that they should not touch a
hot stove because it's harmful when I
watched this video I wanted to gain a
fuller understanding of how this was
done
I read up a little bit on the
corresponding paper to get a deeper
understanding of what this was about
basically the paper states that as
robots are able to do more tasks the
expectations of humans will also grow so
to prepare for this future robots will
need mechanisms to determine when and
how it is best to reject commands that
it receives from humans if you think
about it we do the same thing without
really noticing if your boss or teacher
would ask you to lift up a truck or to
simply fly you would obviously tell them
no because it's literally impossible you
just can't do it
likewise for an ethical dilemma you
would also say no because it goes
against certain cognitive rules that you
follow
so moving further the paper goes on to
propose a general integrated cognitive
robotic platform that determines whether
an instruction should be accepted or
rejected this platform also includes an
explanation as to why the command was
rejected the researchers state that a
command given by a human can only be
strongly executed if it has been
accepted and well understood so we have
to go deeper here how does a robot
actually understand then the answer
comes in the form of the robot thinking
through a specific set of conditions
number one knowledge the robot asks
itself do I know how to do the task
number two capacity am i normally
physically able to do the task number
three goal priority and timing am I able
to do the tasks right now number four
social role and obligation am i
obligated based on my social role to do
the task and number five normative
permissibility finally the robot asks
itself does it violate any normative
principle to do the task that basically
means is it normal to do the task or in
some cases is it morally correct once
all of these conditions are passed the
robot can go on and do the task the
human has said so I wanted to go a
little bit deeper into how this worked
and I ended up on another research paper
interestingly this thought process is
built in a special system called D Ark
which is an acronym that stands for
distributed integrated effect reflection
cognition architecture for robots if all
of that was nonsense basically think of
it like a toolkit that gives robots and
ability to think about questions another
interesting thing that I found is that
the diag toolkit actually allows robots
to perceive vision in two ways a visual
long term and short term memory the
short term memory is used as a working
memory for currently or recently
perceived objects and the long term
memory is used for recalling objects
that were seen in previous days weeks
months
and even years and that should sound
quite familiar because that's the same
system we use as humans so with all of
that said there's one main question that
remains how would we stop the diag
system from incorrectly carrying out a
human instruction that is morally wrong
but it's still accepted by the system
and further to this what do you define
as moral what if there's a gray area
these are difficult questions that can't
be answered at this time it will be up
to the programmers and progressive
machine learning to get it right
all in all robots learning to
distinguish whether human instructions
are appropriate or not is definitely
something to keep an eye on in the
future as all probably become one of the
most important parts of robotic AI
anyway that was just a bit of cutting
edge robotics for you let me know your
thoughts in the comment section below
feel free to subscribe if you're new
here and if you want to know more stuff
on cutting edge technology just chill
out for the next 10 seconds and follow
the prompts in your screen anyway thanks
for watching guys this has been - go go
you have been watching ColdFusion have a
good one and I'll see you again soon for
the next video Cheers ColdFusion it's
you